they were his heroes  and birmingham city warmed up wearing  his name  a message for the little boy who thought  no one loved him  from footballers to their young fan  and in the sixth minute crowds across  the country clapped  the child who seemed so invisible  remembered by thousands and thousands  arthur's family say he dreamt of  becoming a footballer their loss is  unimaginable but it is felt by many  outside the house where he was tortured  and killed the tributes grow and from  the sadness there's anger the mp here  says sentencing was too lenient he's  referred the case to the attorney  general who now has four weeks to decide  whether an appeal can go ahead  there are calls too for reform of the  systems which let down arthur so badly  for now though vigils and a country  united in shock and horror over the evil  inflicted on a little boy  laura bundock sky news